>> WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORK WITH
STATE AND LOCAL LEADERS TO HELP
SECURE OUR SCHOOLS AND TACKLE
THE DIFFICULT ISSUE OF MENTAL
HEALTH.
>> MENTAL HEALTH SOLUTIONS ARE
NOT GOING TO STOP GUN VIOLENCE.
WE NEED STRONGER GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION, BACKGROUND CHECKS.
>> WE HAVE NOT DONE A VERY GOOD
JOB OF MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
THAT HAVE MENTAL REASONS FOR NOT
BEING ABLE TO HANDLE A GUN,
GETTING THEIR NAME INTO THE FBI
FILES.
AND WE NEED TO CONCENTRATE ON
THAT.
>> I'D RATHER PASS GUN SAFETY
LEGISLATION THAN WIN THE
ELECTION.
>> WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED HERE, AND WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO IS WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A REAL CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO STOP IT.
>> Bret: TALK ABOUT ACTION
TODAY, AFTER THAT HORRIBLE
SHOOTING IN FLORIDA YESTERDAY.
17 KILLED.
BUT WHAT IS REAL AND WHAT CAN
POTENTIALLY HAPPEN IN THE
BUILDING BEHIND US, LET'S BRING
IN OUR PANEL.
JUDICIAL ANALYST JUDGE
NAPOLITANO, AND AMY STODDARD,
AND JONATHAN SWAN, NATIONAL
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR AXIOS.
AMY, I'LL START WITH YOU.
WHAT IS REAL?
YOU KNOW, NANCY PELOSI SAID SHE
WOULD RATHER LOSE THE ELECTION
THAN PASS SOMETHING.
BUT WHAT'S POSSIBLE IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT?
>> OH, I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
POSSIBLE, BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
HERE BEFORE.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN GET LEGISLATION
OUT AFTER THE NRA SUPPORTED IT
LAST SUMMER.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT A REAL
OPPORTUNITY HERE.
BOTH SIDES CONTINUE TO DIG IN.
IF YOU WANT TO ACTUALLY CHANGE
THIS, YOU HAVE TO ACTUALLY TAKE
AWAY THE WEAPONRY WITH THE
ABILITY TO KILL SO MANY PEOPLE
SO QUICKLY.
THAT INFRINGES ON ONE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
IF YOU WANT TO STOP -- GET IN
EARLY AND SCREEN SOCIAL MEDIA,
YOU'RE INFRINGING -- WHERE
PEOPLE ARE DESCRIBING THESE
FEELINGS AND THESE PLANS, AND
INTENTIONS OF PHOTOGRAPHS AND
EVERYTHING, YOU'RE TAKING AWAY
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL EXPRESSION
OF FREE SPEECH.
>> Bret: WE HEAR WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAYS.
BUT BEHIND THE SCENES WHAT IS
THE PRESIDENT THINKING?
IS THERE A THINKING ABOUT A
POLICY PUSH?
>> ONE ADVISED ME THAT THIS IS
THEORETICALLY A NIXON-TO-CHINA
OPPORTUNITY.
THE NRA SUPPORTS HIM, HE COULD
ACTUALLY GO THERE.
BUT I DON'T THINK TRUMP WANTS TO
GO TO CHINA.
THIS IS AN ISSUE WHERE HE
ACTUALLY INSTINCTIVELY
UNDERSTANDS.
HE SAID IT IN SPEECHES, HE SAYS,
COMMON COURT BAD, SECOND
AMENDMENT GOOD.
HE'S SEEN IT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, HE UNDERSTANDS IT.
AND THERE WAS NOBODY WHO
SUPPORTED HIM MORE STRONGLY
DURING THE CAMPAIGN THAN THE
NRA.
I DON'T SEE TRUMP ACTING AGAINST
THE NRA'S INTERESTS ON THIS
ISSUE.
>> Bret: HERE'S THE PRESIDENT ON
MAKING SCHOOLS SAFER.
>> LATER THIS MONTH, I WILL BE
MEETING WITH THE NATION'S
GOVERNORS AND ATTORNEY GENERALS,
WE'RE MAKING OUR SCHOOLS AND
CHILDREN SAFER WILL BE OUR TOP
PRIORITY.
IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO SIMPLY TAKE
ACTIONS THAT MAKE US FEEL LIKE
WE ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE, WE
MUST ACTUALLY MAKE THAT
DIFFERENCE.
>> I DIDN'T GET THE AUDIO IN THE
FIRST HALF, BUT I THINK HE'S
RIGHT.
I SHOULD ALSO SAY, YOU KNOW, I
AGREE WITH A.B. THAT WE ARE IN A
POLITICAL STALEMATE.
JUST THE SECOND THIS NEWS BROKE,
I THINK EVERYBODY WHO TALKS
ABOUT THESE THINGS
PROFESSIONALLY, THEIR SOUL JUST
GOT WEIGHTED DOWN, JUST WITH THE
PROSPECT OF THE SAME ARGUMENTS
ON BOTH SIDES.
WHICH I THINK ARE VALID
ARGUMENTS AND IMPORTANT
ARGUMENTS AND ALL THE REST.
BUT IF THERE IS A STALEMATE IN
THE POLITICAL SYSTEM, THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE REST OF
SOCIETY CAN'T ADJUST TO THESE
THINGS.
THERE CAN BE AN ISRAELI STYLE
HARDENING OF THE SCHOOLS.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT TACTICS THAT
PEOPLE CAN TAKE.
I AGREE WITH A.B. THAT THE -- IF
THE GOVERNMENT GETS INVOLVED,
AND USING AI, OR SOMETHING TO
MONITOR COMMENTS ON THE WEB,
THAT GETS INTO SERIOUS FIRST
AMENDMENT ISSUES.
AND WE'LL HAVE HIM SET HIS HAIR
ON FIRE.
>> Bret: ACCORDING TO THE JUDGE
NEXT DOOR.
>> BUT THERE ARE, YOU KNOW --
THIS GUY WAS SAYING, YEAH, HE
SAID IN A YOUTUBE COMMENT
SECTION, I'M GOING TO BE A
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL SHOOTER.
>> Bret: RIGHT.
>> THAT IS A RED FLAG.
IT WAS SENT TO THE FBI.
>> Bret: LET'S PLAY THAT, THE
SPECIAL AGENT TALKING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED THERE WITH THE FBI.
>> IN 2017, THE FBI RECEIVED
INFORMATION ABOUT A COMMENT MADE
ON A YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
THE COMMENT SIMPLY SAID, I'M
GOING TO BE A PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOL SHOOTER.
NO OTHER INFORMATION WAS
INCLUDED WITH THAT COMMENT,
WHICH WOULD INDICATE A TIME,
LOCATION, OR THE TRUE IDENTITY
OF THE PERSON WHO MADE THE
COMMENT.
THE FBI CONDUCTED DATABASE
REVIEWS, CHECKS, BUT WAS UNABLE
TO FURTHER IDENTIFY THE PERSON
WHO ACTUALLY MADE THE COMMENT.
WE DO NOT KNOW IF IT'S THE SAME
PERSON.
>> Bret: JUDGE?
>> I ESSENTIALLY AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID.
AND MY HEART SANK KNOWING I WAS
GOING TO HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
THIS, BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A
TRAGEDY.
AND I LIKE THE ISRAELI MODEL.
THE SCHOOL DOORS ARE LOCKED, AND
TWO OR THREE OF THE TEACHERS ARE
TRAINED TO CARRY.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHICH TEACHERS
THEY ARE.
THEY DO NOT CARRY OPENLY.
THEY CARRY SILENTLY, AND IN A
HIDDEN WAY.
AND HOW MANY SCHOOL KILLINGS ARE
THERE IN ISRAEL?
NONE.
THAT ALL CAN BE DONE BY THE
FLORIDA LEGISLATURE.
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
CONGRESS.
CONGRESS CAN'T PASS A BUDGET, OR
DACA, WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT IN A
LITTLE WHILE.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS WHETTED
TO THE NRA.
THAT'S A NONSTARTER.
AND THIS THING CALLED THE SECOND
AMENDMENT, WHICH THEY'VE ALL
TAKEN A NOTE TO UPHOLD AND THE
SUPREME COURT HAS INTERPRETED AS
IT HAS IN A VERY PRO-INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS WAY.
>> Bret: IS THE MENTAL HEALTH
PUSH, YOU KNOW, THAT TALKING
ABOUT THIS, SOMETHING THAT THEY
CAN GET DONE WITH SOMETHING
ELSE, AND AT LEAST AROUND THE
EDGES TRY TO ATTACK IT?
>> WELL, THEY'VE ALREADY PASSED
SOME LEGISLATION THAT WAS
POINTED OUT, THE 21st CENTURY
THAT TOUCHES ON MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
YOU'LL HAVE THE LEFT SAYING THIS
IS JUST A SMOKE SCREEN FOR THE
REAL ISSUE, WHICH IS BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
EVERYBODY RETREATS TO THEIR
CAMPS IMMEDIATELY.
IT'S HARD TO SEE WHERE THE
COMMON GROUND IS.
>> Bret: LOOK AT THIS DEAL.
HE GETS THE AR-15 LEGALLY.
HE BUYS IT LEGALLY.
HE PASSES THE BACKGROUND CHECK.
I MEAN, SOMETHING HAPPENED.
>> AND THAT IS WHY THE GUN
CONTROL SIDE WILL ARGUE THAT THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE NOT
RESTRICTIVE ENOUGH.
THAT YOU ARE STILL PERMITTED TO
BUY A FIREARM WHEN YOU --
>> Bret: HAVE BEEN EXPELLED
FROM --
>> HAD PROBLEMS.
AND THAT THEY WOULD ARGUE THAT
IF YOU CAN'T DRINK ALCOHOL, WHY
ARE YOU CARRYING AN AR-15 AROUND
AT AGE 18?
>> I WANT TO POINT OUT, I KNOW
THE NRA BECOMES THE SHORTHAND IN
THESE CONVERSATIONS.
BUT THE NRA, IF YOU LISTEN TO
SOME PEOPLE ON SOME OTHER
NETWORKS, THEY TALK ABOUT HOW
ALL THESE POLITICIANS ARE OWNED
BY THE NRA, AND HOW DONALD TRUMP
IS BEHOLDING TO THE NRA.
THE NRA DOESN'T GIVE THAT MUCH
MONEY INTO POLITICS LIKE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS.
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS IS THEY'RE
ACTUALLY ORGANIZING AND
COMMUNICATING WITH ACTUAL
VOTERS.
AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES THEM SO
EFFECTIVE.
>> Bret: IF YOU POLL IN THESE
SWING STATES, IT'S THROUGH THE
ROOF.
THAT'S NOT NRA, THAT'S --
>> THAT'S NOT THE NRA, BEHOLDING
TO THE VOTERS WHO GET YOU
ELECTED.
>> SUGGESTING THIS IS A MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE IS A DIVERSION.
IT'S AN ISSUE OF NOT ENOUGH
SUPERIOR FIREPOWER TO STOP THESE
KILLERS.
IF HE'S CRAZY, HE'S GOING TO
FIND A WAY TO KILL.
IF HE'S IRRATIONAL AND WANTS TO
KILL, HE WILL FIND A WAY TO
KILL.
>> Bret: THERE ARE 300 MILLION
GUNS.
>> LIKE A SITTING DUCK.
>> I TALKED TO A SENIOR WHITE
HOUSE OFFICIAL ABOUT THIS TODAY
AND I SAID, WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
DO?
320 MILLION GUNS IN THIS
COUNTRY, ARE WE GOING TO DO WHAT
MY COUNTRY DID AND TRY TO BUY